have you ever had an ambitious idea a
goal a dream and you're like yes I'm
gonna do it but then the looming
realization that you're not a
billionaire and you do not have
unlimited resources at your fingertips
kicks in and then you have to
drastically scale down on that idea
because overextending your expectations
will most definitely lead to
disappointment
well I say that it's the restrictions
like not having the right resources of
the right tools that stop this shitty
creative block and you're like what am I
gonna do and then it's just dead Rock
I'm gonna show you what you can do
anything you want by not thinking about
things traditionally by not following
the herd and going against the grain
through utilizing the pioneers of
law-breaking us filmmakers I have worked
as a professional film director on
really major since 500 people states
with all kinds of gear spinning all over
the place I've then also worked at the
YouTube space where I've utilized myself
as a functional proper in very many
dangerous scenarios I've had pieces of
drones hit me on the head and dragged
behind cars I've fallen off buildings I
think that it's safe to say that I've
gone full spectrum with shooting on
pretty much every single piece of gear
from shitty yeah to really highly
professional gear that you can possibly
utilize therefore I've chosen five what
we call shitty rig examples which are
essentially filmmakers that have used
their desperation in order to get the
shot with no money to recreate a
Hollywood style looking foam or shocked
I'm gonna put these really shitty rigs
together and put them to the test
along with my assistant Sean who's
actually been disguised in the shot the
entire time you can come out on
y'all now this is our very first shitty
rig setup I've got your normal
remote-control car just a just a simple
plain remote-control car nothing special
with a GoPro attached literally Gavin
taped around the car to give us a kind
of emotion feel I saw this image on the
shitty rigs blog and I thought it would
work really well for skateboarding so we
got torn he's gonna do some
skateboarding maneuvers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice I get out of pain out rate this
running around a seven
it's a little bit unreliable with the
controls
but it's a lot of fun and I think I
think we got some good shots okay let's
go to number two hadn't accepted welcome
to the second example of the shitty rigs
this one I call the fish tank why well
because it's a little fish tank with a
camera inside it why would you want to
do something so ridiculous well if you
didn't have a GoPro and underwater
camera and you wanted to try and get
some crispy slow-motion underwater shots
might be a pretty good option I saw this
video online and then I saw this
photograph and has decided to combine
the two so I got a stand up paddle board
with a rope and flan on it as well as a
swimmer Amy and it's raining so thank
you for doing this let's see how this
goes
oh this is a seriously shitty rig so I
would raid this one around a five out of
ten
it's a lot of effort seems pretty
unreliable also dropping the glass in
the swimming pool would be very
dangerous and it was cold I don't know
if the actress was very happy what do
you rated on one attain
this is the third and by far the
craziest shitty rigs example well I
pulled this one the Nadia hand hold car
job stable stable safe safe very
dangerous do not try this at home
Rick I saw this for anybody from Twitter
a few years ago and ever since then I've
really wanted to recreate a shot where I
go looking at the trees moved on slowly
panning and then establish my subject
which will be a love scenario in the
back of the vehicle I just really want
to emphasize please do not try this at
home
I am a professional that's done I've
done this kind of stuff before okay and
but I don't want anyone else really
trying this please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that one is a difficult one to rate I
would say I'm inclined to say 8 out of
10 for cinematic value but a low two out
of 10 for the pain and effort it took to
actually get that shot I think it would
be cheaper to just hire Jeb you know on
his feet but it was cool
nevertheless let's to 8:00 let's meet in
the middle and call it a 5
[Music]
this is the fourth example of a shitty
rig I call this one the Blair Witch
crotch cam tripod dangle stable GoPro
holder directing short films and
commercials before I've done the shot a
lot of times but with with a
professional rig and the shot looks
something like this
but yeah I'm gonna reenact with Amy a
scene kind of like Blair Witch Project
where she's running away through
something scary and that we don't really
know where it is or what it is and she's
lost and we're using the warp on the
camera along with the stabilization of
this crotch camera attachment we're
losing light so let's do it
number four what would you rate this a -
G - uncomfortable circumstances to do -
uncomfortable circumstances for all Amy
I would say a 4 I looked at the footage
that's pretty cool but yeah I mean you
can't put your cost member under strain
that's a no-go so 2 out of 10 no 4 out
of 10 let's meet in the middle 3 out of
10 this is the fifth and final shitty
rig it's by far my favorites I would
give this a 10 out of 10 before we go
forwards I just want to play this clip
[Music]
I really really wanted to recreate this
effect with a vape I even went and
bought one but torn and I don't vape
Nash I'm gonna leave it up to to these
guys who did it perfectly and hand that
one over as a 10 out of 10 so if you are
vape nature and you don't use a lot of
vapor and you have a lot of vaping
friends and you can't afford a smoke
machine well well there you have it you
can you convey Bri I hope you enjoyed
the video this was an illustration of
how I tackle creative block in my life
and I partnered up with the one and only
Adobe for the Adobe MAX inspiration
engine which is an awesome part of the
Adobe MAX of aints happening in LA next
week and this is seriously cool if you
have an Alexa tell her enable the Adobe
inspiration engine and I'll be one of
the voices that you hear which is super
rad then something even more exciting
you may have seen on my social media I'm
going to select one lucky person who are
fly to Los Angeles to create a film with
me from pre-production production and
will editor together to be involved it's
super simple
there's just two things you need to do
one is to subscribe to the Adobe
Creative Cloud YouTube channel two is
two-person example of how you overcame
creative block in your life it could be
a photo a piece of art a video you could
tailor a video just for this but it's
important to mention in the description
how you over
your creative block and remember to make
use of the two hashtags which are Adobe
in spa engine and Adobe X down and then
drop a comment down below this video to
let me know that you've done so and for
the full lowdown visit Adobe dot ly /
Dan Mays Cola which is linked in the
description below and lastly don't
forget your awesome route and I'll see
you next week